wait these are cardboard cutouts
you're ruining the illusion opening
credits i thought these were real
children
the fact that when they create kenny in
this opening they also quickly kill him
is subtle and beautiful and smart and
crap i'm already taking a sin off
but also who looked at this already
cocaine-fueled rush of images and said
you know what this needs
another diy layer on top of it to really
bring home the seizures
i don't need to take any lip from a
freaking girl that's magest
stan stan hang on guys my dad wants
something
sure but why would your avatar stop and
react like it was hearing your dad too
i am socializing thinking abbreviation
makes it okay
i'm logged on to an mmorpg with people
from all over the world
10 year olds playing online games with
strangers from all over the world i'm
getting xp with my party using teamspeak
teamspeak also this is a good reminder
that all that talk about zooming each
other and tv and movies is going to
sound ridiculous very very soon
like maybe even already soon hanging
your posters crooked
especially this crooked you're basically
the poster child for not straightening
up your posters
child also this light switch is on the
wrong side of this door how are you
supposed to turn on the lights when you
enter the room if the door's blocking
the switch
come on trey and matt paying attention
to these kind of important details could
have made your show successful
i'm sure the goal here was to squeeze in
as many gamer stereotypes into one frame
as possible
so congrats i guess more people calling
in about their characters getting killed
first day on the helpline betsy you know
there's a mute call and hold button
available right
as opposed to the vaguely sound
dampering properties of human flesh
i've gotta get home my kids are playing
world of warcraft right now
forgetting to use the phone how do you
kill that which has no life
well my friend was once on the way to
denny's for moons over my hammy and his
car died he got so mad he took a tire
iron to the dead car battery destroying
it while yelling my moons were meant to
be over my hammies
so i guess what i'm saying is you can
always try see
i'm a hunter level two i made the
mistake of telling my cousin donnie that
we were sinning this episode and he
wanted me to make sure and mention that
this
character is human and apparently humans
couldn't actually be hunters until some
sort of update
called and i'm not sure i'm right about
this the cat and crimson edition
nailed it you're welcome donnie donnie
also wants me to mention that carmen
just said
we will meet here on the plains of the
open forest near westwood and yet they
appear to have gathered oh what was it
something about the baby back mountain
region beside the lord boromir
internment camp
anyhow apparently it's at least four
regions away from the actual edinguin
forest who's the wow expert now donnie
no no you can just hang outside in the
sun all day tossing a ball around
or you can sit at your computer and do
something that matters cinemasins staff
meeting pep talk somehow makes its way
into the show
also taking the outdoors for granted
boring montages
why are we montaging through the first
week of september when kyle's calendar
already has half of october crossed off
unless you think that's just a
mid-montage thing where time is relative
he had those days crossed off at the
beginning of the episode too is that
half a donut on his desk have you ever
tried to set half a donut down after
taking a bite it's against the laws of
god and man
you finish that donut or you forfeit
your right to future fried dough treats
sir you better have a look at this you
better come take a look at this cliche
although they're likely making fun of it
in the show itself so i'm not sure what
to even do here
hang on jeremy you might want to come
take a look at this dang it
they've established that there's nothing
they can do to beat the killer except
level up so
what does he hope to find in the
magazine at this point the kids would
know better than anyone how to kill a
boar
also this sink has no faucet we must get
this sword to the ones who have proven
they have no life
or and this may be insane ask someone in
the adjacent workroom there at wow
headquarters to make a quick
tune and give the sword to yourself but
you do you show
you do you man yes han
more hot pocket right away hon that's
uber cool
more like uber eats actually everyone
target the scorpions
not pictured scorpions we are looking
for a great knight
by the name of love's to spooj that's my
son's character's name in warcraft
is it though because earlier he was
playing under the name stan is cool
which had the added benefit of not using
numbers or strange word spellings or
being based around the concept of
ejaculation
unless they have this sword your son's
character is going to die
except he won't he'll respond so why is
drama
you have to keep playing this
instruction rings hollow from someone
who stopped playing so he could help
another player who stopped playing do
something that the first player who
stopped playing could probably have done
himself anyway
if we could get to a computer we could
sign on to the world of warcraft and
give the boys the sword online
oh like for example the computers that
were surrounding you back at blizzard hq
help stop please it's an emergency
come on accidentally including grand
theft auto into your world of warcraft
episode
wasting most of a perfectly good chip
because it touched your shirt
wow just wow
the armor spells are down attack makes
as much sense as in game i guess
my mother says video games are bad for
you three pillow patties
have a glorious commercials
[Music]
[Music]
commercials
[Music]
[Music]
fellow board members we have a problem
and
you will
atone hmm looks like that guy just
killed you well it just so happens that
your friend here is only
mostly dead what about
the sword of a thousand truths listen
strange women lying in ponds
distributing swords there's no basis for
a system of government
apparently it could cause 120 damage per
second with an instant mana burn
and an enchantment that boosted stamina
plus 80.
[Music]
behold the sword of a thousand truths
you killed my father prepare to die